good afternoon and welcome to this
meeting at the mid-suffolk planning
referrals committee my name is Claire
Philpott and I'm the governance officer
for this meeting the first item of
business will be the election of a chair
for the meeting
members asked to note that should the
vote be drawn there will be no casting
vote and the vote will be taken again
and the till the chair is elected
please could I ask for nominations for a
chair
Council Matheson
I nominate councilor Stringer
thank you are there any other
nominations
councilor I think councilor Mayo was
did you have
thank you I'd like to nominate councilor
Muller
can I have a seconder for councilor
Stringer first please
Council of warboys and a secondar for
councilor Muller
thank you councilor now so if we do
these via a show of hands so can I have
a show of hands for counselor Stringer
please
oh thank you and can I have a show of
hands for Council of Mueller please
no it's fine I make that five for
councilman Muller therefore councilman
Muller will take the chair
for the meeting thank you we'll have a
short break while we spot sweets thank
you
thank you
may I first of all remind you some
domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptops are switched to silent
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record a film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via a fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point which is
Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium rain floor area and
walkways if you are in the atrium at the
time of the alarm follow the signs to
the nearest fire exit use the stairs not
the lists do not re-enter the building
and told it is safe to do so I'd like to
make some introductions we have the
chief planning officer Mr Philip Isbell
the Strategic projects and delivery
manager is not here legal advisor Mr Ian
dupres case officer Mr Vincent Pierce
and the governor's office Clearfield and
Alicia Norman we have the war members
here also thanks Lee Davis and councilor
Richardson
can I move to the agenda please item one
apologies for absence and substitutions
please thank you chair we have apologies
from Council
of gold councilor Guthrie councilor
Norris and councilor Passmore thank you
very much
item two to receive decorations of
disposable pecuniary interests and other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare please
none
of Declarations of lobbying
no okay
Declarations of personal site visits
right item five
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of January 2021
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes uh could I have
a proposal and a second of please
councilor Caston and councilor Mathison
thank you and the governance officer
will now conduct the electronic vote
thank you
chair members that vote is now in
progress councilor Stringer can I take
your vote please and four please thank
you
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for that's unanimous thank you
very much item six to confirm the
minutes confirmation of minutes held on
the 19th of March 2021
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the minutes
not could I have a proposal and a second
to please councilor mayor and councilor
mayor Mansell was second thank you and I
now like to read ask the government's
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please
chair mum does that vote is in progress
Council Stringer
well thank you
thank you members chair that is nine
votes four so that again is Gary thank
you thank you very much item seven to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
thank you very much
therefore we move to item eight which is
the schedule of planning applications
and item 8A which is DC
19020 90 land to the east of ixsworth
Road Thurston Suffolk and I would now
like to invite the case officer Vincent
Pierce to introduce the application to
the committee Thank You Vince
good afternoon members guests
and anyone who may be watching or
listening to this online
as you will see from my report this is
an application that Members First
considered
back in 2020.
the site itself is shown on the screen
in
it's north of Norton Road and to the
northeast of the Thurston Community
College
you'll notice from the screen that there
are a number of sites around it
developed
once he's under construction
as is the Linden homes one the Lawrence
homes one is not so advanced
as I say back in 2020 the committee
considered this three times ending up in
September 2020 with a resolution to
Grant planning permission outline
planning permission for 210 dwellings
subject to a 106 agreement
that 106 was drafted and does exist
however that decision was not issue
on the basis that we'd had indication
that were the permission to be issued it
would be likely to be challenged by
Thurston Parish Council on a point of
Law and as members will recall we
already had a Jr challenge in respect of
the Baton Road application also in
Thurston
since you last considered the
application we believe as often as there
has been a material change in
circumstance
which means it is right and proper to
bring this application back to committee
because the issue the decision was not
issued and therefore
a council is still in the position to
determine that at all application
however
we have now received an appeal or
notification of an appeal against
non-determination Gladwin the applicants
have decided to appeal on the
the council has not decided the
application
so what I'm going to be doing this
afternoon
is
describing the scheme and then
recommending that had an appeal not been
lodged or
thistle would have refused the
application on the basis of the material
change in circumstance since September
so
as officers we've completely reversed
our previous recommendation and we are
now recommending refusal
the Two Chief changes in material
circumstances are that the time you
considered this previously The jlp Joint
local plan was proceeding
and we advised you that it represented
the direction of travel
the council in terms of allocations
Thurston even though in itself it
carried little weight
it's a material planning consideration
so I I'll go into a little bit more
detail shortly but at the time the
council was intending to allocate this
site
for housing
because part two of The Joint local plan
is now no longer preceding the council's
only proceeding with part one all those
allocations effectively now been dropped
and we are relying on allocations within
the adopted
local plan
within the adopted local plan this site
is not allocated for development it is
in fact Countryside
the other material change in
circumstance members will recall way
back
2020 2019 2018 there was a lot of
concern the council was its five-year
housing lend Supply position was at
times precarious
We Now find ourselves
several years later in a position where
we can demonstrate that we now have a
10.88
year housing land Supply
on that basis
we do not feel that there is an
overriding need to support additional
housing
where it's contrary to policy and I will
go into a little bit more detail as we
go through the presentation
so that's the order of the headline
changes
that's why we're here this afternoon
reviewing the position and as officers
providing you with a revised
planning balance and conclusion in the
report
previously we looked at a a lot of
elements of the scheme
in my presentation this afternoon I will
describe them but as officers we are not
going to contradict what we said about
the benefits of the scheme as previously
described
so we are literally going to look at how
the material change in circumstance has
affected our recommendation to you
as always this presentation is merely
meant to supplement the detail
ing child report
just to remind members Thurston is a key
service center in the adopted local plan
and it is a site a location where we
expect
development the majority of development
directed in terms of our settlement
hierarchy
here we have an extract from the
Thurston inset from the adopted
development plan you'll notice that the
yellow star which indicates the position
of the site is outside of the defined
settlement boundary
appears in your
adopted
development plan
similarly
obviously we have a
an adopted
development plan in Thurston
that includes
a settlement boundary as defined in the
neighborhood plan which sits thus as in
Gray you'll notice again that the
application site is outside of
full system
as defined in the adopted neighborhood
plan
on the screen is a
plan that I presented last time
an extract from The Joint local plan and
you'll see in green
la089 we see at application site was
potentially allocated for housing
development that no longer exists there
is no such allocation that has now been
dropped
along with
that being dropped is the actual text
that underpinned that allocation which
identified the site as suitable for
approximately 200 dwellings that also
has been withdrawn
the site therefore remains Countryside
in accordance with your adopted
development plan
as local authorities all local
authorities attempt to be at least to be
able to demonstrate they have a
five-year housing lens Supply
the fortunate position in mid-suffolk of
having a 10.88 year Supply so we have
significant
availability and that is likely to be
able to take us to the end of or very
close to the end of the present
review local plan period of 2036.
9 counselors this is
an indication of the development that
has already been approved
in Thurston and these sites constitute
what is colloquially known as the first
and five
that adds up to
818 dwellings North and just a little
bit to the south of Northern Road but if
effectively North Thurston
is in the process of receiving
818 dwellings all of those have
permission and have been identified in
the neighborhood plan
and you'll notice that the if you could
remember the previous plan from the
neighborhood plan itself the settlement
boundary was extended in the
neighborhood plan to Encompass those
sites
the site with the red star
I.E the application site was not
included
we now have it confirmed the outline
planning permission
also now lawfully exists on the bait and
roadside so that's an additional 210
dwellings in Thurston
so that brings us up to a thousand in
Thurston and we have the extra care unit
on Heath Road which is an additional 54
you
I'm sure we will hear representations
from the parish council
I'm sure it's their belief that over a
thousand properties Thurston how has
actually
contributed significantly to satisfying
demand across the district in terms of
the current plan period
so the flashing yellow sites of the
sites that are well under construction
orange dotted site is the Lawrence homes
site which has yet to make big impact in
terms of progress
and item road we have the reserved
matters at
likely to come to community
of March and
the reserve matters details for 210
dwellings and that was the case that was
subject to the Jr challenge
so in terms of proposed access let's
orientate ourselves we've got ixsworth
road on the left and Norton Road
off the screen
Meadow Lane on the right so the site
sits in between those two
sections of Highway let's see if we can
the main access will be at the southern
end
at this point with an emergency access
for fire ambulance police Etc at the
Northern end
and it is laid out in a series of
perimeter blocks this layout changed
throughout the lifetime of the
application because
do was to secure stronger Green links
across the site
so that photograph is taken at that
particular access point looking East
across this Farmland so the application
site sits in in here
as you can see from the
the inset on the left
what we have secured
bear in mind that North is now to the
right of that so I've turned it through
90 degrees to show you the
visibility display that's
is required
and behind that will be a 20 meter deep
landscape buffer where this to be
approved
so in terms of what that would look like
viewed from the air just to give you a
better idea
of the Rugby Club down here
this Frontage along here would be dense
planting at the moment
the site edge of the societies
characterize really by removed Hedgerow
the odd little groupings a few
occasional single trees but most of the
Hedgerow that would have lined this
ixworth road have been removed
again at that entrance there will be
footway cycleway connections
to the crossing point shown here members
may recall that the persimmon site which
is in here has already now provided a
three meter wide footway cycleway that
goes right down to the Community College
so this site would plug into that
evolving Network
oh
cool okay
sorry if I
okay sorry
apologies
should I go back one slide and re-jiggle
my mouse
because I I wouldn't want anyone to feel
so
again here we are at the southern access
there will be sections of three meter
wide footway cycleway installed at the
Crossing Point here
which would then plug into
three meter wide footway cycleway that
has been provided by persimmon
will go right the way down into the
village itself to the Community College
on the corner
so this would be plugged into an
evolving network of
cycleway systems in Thurston
it'd be able to go from that Crossing
Footwear circuit right the way down to
the college and you'll remember
to Thurston is particularly well
provided with
a cycle Network as a national cycle
Route 51 does go through
The Village
a standout feature of the scheme that we
presented last time was this large area
of open space
which has been secured or members to
approve this
scheme which we're now not recommending
but I do need to identify the benefits
this would be transfer to the council
for a pound
and potentially would offer
all kinds of
facilities for the village
so that's the area of open space within
this scheme which you know which would
actually sit adjacent to another large
area of open space which is secured in
the Linden home schemes
on the adjoining site to the east
so again that potentially offers a
buffer between urban development and the
countryside Beyond
the time we also secured a 20 meter wide
buffer on the Eastern edge of the site
along Meadow Lane
at the request specific request of the
committee in order to ensure that the
character of Meadow Lane
highly countrified and the impact of
Urban Development was not able to make a
strong presence on that
that route
so
oh four edges of the site would be
heavily landscaped with species that you
would expect
to see the southern boundary also has a
similar treatment
you can see the
East-West
corridor
and these are actual tape speed speed
tables so pedestrians would go through
this green Corridor and have points of
crossing over the internal estate Road
system
there'd also be accessed pedestrian
access into Meadow Lane itself
from this network
in terms of recreation the 106 secures a
200 000 pound contribution
um
to be used in the first instance to
provide facilities within that area of
open space and that and at the time
there was a lot of discussion around
could that be used for wheel play
skate park BMX Etc
and the site itself would lend itself to
that sort of
use so secured as part of the
illustrative layout and by condition is
this
internal circular route
that would only have one road
Crossing it so we thought
this could easily provide some sort of
jogging Trail dog walking trail
Etc
if you then put some Loops in you could
actually get around the entire estate
and back
without having to cross cross a road you
just loop back in
to return this is the area where we
potentially thought skate park activity
may be possible
it is a an objective in the neighborhood
plan to secure as CI Park and the parish
council would look to a number of sites
site in Thurston some of those are still
under discussion this particular
potentially offered an alternative to
those sites
sorry
sorry I should be sitting the other way
let's go quickly back then so
this is the only point at which the
circular route would have to cross a
road so with these Loops at either end
you could actually go around the entire
estate
turn back and just do continuous
pedestrian friendly
healthy activity jogging walking dog
walking
this is where we thought
the best location for skate park type
activity would would be located
say it is an objective in labor plan to
secure those facilities
and what we were looking at the time is
is a newer idea in skate skating circles
is the idea of skate dots rather than a
single skate park where you have all the
facilities and this
you actually have them drawn out in a
linear form
and you move between the elements
I'll show you a quick diagram here we
believe there's sufficient distance from
the Residential Properties to provide
socially
friendly
juxtaposition so the skate borders would
not annoy the
the residents but there would still be a
high degree of supervision
so on the left you have the more
traditional form of
skate park
and this is the idea of the skate dots
where you move through the landscape in
a series of
skating activities
activity
get back
the site would be highly connected
to a number of points around the village
including the
station
including in the scheme here we have the
ixworth road station Hill Norton Road
conditions so we have the Community
College over here
now one of the big issues
actually the amount of coaches
arrive and leave during the day and
perilous
position of pedestrians largely it's
called children and pupils as they try
and cross these little Junctions
we can get that to work
which we can't some reason but you can
actually see there is a child standing
there what happens is they cross the
road here and
that's the other side that leads into
part of the residential estate so they
all try and cross at this point and
there's a continuous stream of coaches
and they actually sort of dash out
between coaches
see this coach swings around they just
got to the pavement and that coach is
already quite a way into
The Junction
that is not an ideal position it isn't
safe and
we looked at providing oh there you go
and then I think there were probably
about 13 coaches when I took this piece
of video last time and it's just a
continuous stream
what we actually have is these are the
footways
some cycleways but those
people were trying to cross to get into
this footpath system that takes them
into this estate
so there's danger at this point and
what we secured as part of this scheme
is a tiger Crossing
and a tiger Crossing allows
cycles and pedestrians to cross at the
same time within their own defined strip
so it was a New Concept to mid-suffolk
at the time and I don't think we've
actually secured many since
since so looking at that Junction in
Greater detail within the 106 there is
now a commitment to provide these
Crossings
in this position here so you can now see
how how much safer that Junction would
be
for pedestrians and cyclists with this
in in place
also included was a crossing at the
heath Road Barton Road Junction again
which takes a large number of school
children
in the morning and obviously in the
afternoon when they all go back home
this would be a toucan Crossing
by a
three meter wide section of
footway cycleway
societies well connected to the school
the news Primary School off on the right
on this during the community college and
down into Thurston itself in the railway
station
I didn't read my lips then
um sorry counselor yeah
so here's the station here's the site
and down station Hill there is a network
of cycle routes already here you have
the
Community Center and the large area of
open space in the in the heart of the
village
as I said earlier National cycle Route
51 does go through Thurston
see
it's the community college so the site
itself would sit in here
in here and could easily plug into that
system
not a bus routes it's a it's well served
by bus
imperatively speaking to other rural
settlements
and again it has the advantage of having
a railway station which few Villages
have in
mid-suffolk but members will recall the
the issue we have in Thurston in terms
of access to both stations the
down track and the up track you have to
cross the railway lines using a barrow
Crossing
that potentially of course is not safe
even though there are Collections and
warning signs you do have to cross live
railway lines with trains
so at the moment as the report says we
are exploring with network rail the
parish council and our infrastructure
team whether there is still money to try
and come up with a solution that
provided safer access to the westbound
platform
didn't involve or doesn't involve having
to cross those tracks in a sense that's
outside of this application but it does
give you a little bit more background
the only connection between this
application and that potential project
is that this would fund thirty thousand
pounds towards feasibility work on that
project if it were approved
site is located in West
donations Within
the scheme also would provide a
contribution money towards improvements
at Bunbury arms you recall at the top of
ixsworth Road
council is or the County Council is
already looking to improve the Bunbury
arms Junction using
money from the first and five
developments what this scheme
potentially was offering was a
contribution that would pay for mover
software
which wasn't included in the original
schema mover software allows traffic
lights to be controlled in real time by
the cues of traffic at each of those
sets of Lights
so it's far more respect responsive to
flow of traffic where the queues are and
can keep traffic moving more freely
that was considered a benefit by
the highway Authority because the
original scheme did not and does not
include mover
explains what mover is
these are the junction improvements that
have been secured as part of the blower
scheme at Baton Road obviously were this
scheme in North North Thurston to be
approved
it would also take advantage of having
those improvements
in terms of residential immunity we
didn't identify any particular problems
with the site
there have been well recorded issues in
North
Thurston associated with the amount of
construction traffic that there is in
the area obviously with
four major sites under construction
there is a lot of hgv movement a lot of
the verges have been churned up there's
been a lot of road closures local people
have had to endure a long period of of
inconvenience
that in itself is not a material
planning consideration however locally
it is a very
controversial point because as we say
that's now been going on for some two
years
a point that came up last time was what
access is there in the village to a GP
and the answer at the time and it's
still the answer is
Thurston does not have its own GP
practice
residents either go to wool pit or to
debenham
and what we did have was a request from
the Health provider that were
permissioned to be granted or
um
still money would be available to expand
surgeries at these points
I don't think that has changed unless
others say to the country
in terms of biodiversity we're the
scheme to be approved there will be
large areas of new Hedgerow there'd be a
new Wetland area in terms of the suds
system and the attenuation fund new
grasslands a lot of potential for
biodiversity but bear in mind at the
moment of course it is a field
it doesn't have development on it
um
and all of this biodiversity is only
required because of that development
moving on
in terms of the 106 that has been
secured
we have education contributions worth
nearly one and a half million in terms
of expending Education provision in the
in the village
we have that transfer of open space for
a pound
the two hundred thousand pound towards
open space sport Recreation
a cyclist discount contribution of 31
and a half thousand pounds which would
provide residents with discounted
deals to purchase Cycles
the thirty thousand pounds towards
station feasibility
and then there's a whole series of other
benefits
we do get a 35 affordable housing
comes when we look at the balance again
because
we were pointing out to you as I said at
the start this site potentially was
going to be allocated for 200 dwellings
and the direction of travel was to add
more development to
to that which existed in the neighbor
plant in first
we also pointed out the potentially
less robust position
in terms of the higher five-year housing
land Supply
our balance at the time was because of
fell towards approving the
development because of the benefits
secured through the section 106
agreement
however
today when we look and we reflect on
that position and the new position we
find ourselves in
I'm this is okay I don't need the don't
need the point for this one
um as I said earlier today that site is
not allocated there are no allocations
in Thurston or any part of the district
appearing in the joint local plan
so the direct there is no direction of
travel towards allocating this site or
any other site
planner wants to just
just at the moment that's the direction
of travel but until the modification is
document the jlp is published
that's almost the position
it's not literally true that the plan
has been split into two
so the inspectors agree that that's the
approach and that's part of the
correspondence that has taken place
between us and Them
hasn't yet actually formally been done
through a modification to the jlp that
is I believe happens soon and when that
happens I'll be
rotation so it's not the done deal but
reading between the lines with
everything else we are almost at that
point of it being
I'll leave it there please thank you
okay I'm grateful to the chief playing
officer because
as we found out
these things can lead to all sorts of
consequences if I don't accurate
describe the
I'm grateful to feel full
highlighting the issue
and of course we now have a
nearly an 11-year housing land Supply
and our feeling is that has material
materially shifted that balance
whilst we've still got this basket of
benefits you may see them as benefits or
less than the benefit but at the time we
said there were benefits that outweighed
and now is
that actually the harm to the
adopted
development plan in terms of development
within the countryside when there is
strong and robust position in terms of
our five-year housing land Supply does
tip the balance away from an approval
and towards refusal
and that's why in the report we are now
recommending that had an appear not been
lodged this Council would have refused
the application a lot has happened in
the intervening two and a half years
and that materially affects the
recommendation that we are now providing
future thank you very much we have
members questions please okay so
Matheson then came from the Maxwell
thank you Chef
um yeah page um 35
um are you sexually liked
um
yeah the I think it would be
helpful to say you you did say that the
The Five-Year land Supply position at
the time of the original recommendation
was precarious
um I think if we actually had a date
at which it became more than five
um the the that date as compared to the
date when we made the the um
decision that we made
um I think that would that would be very
useful
um
the the other question
um there's a reference
um
on
page here we are page 33
um yeah I wasn't clear
you mentioned finally the Supreme Court
in the second paragraph there I had not
heard that the the Supreme Court had
made a decision about this um
long-running um court case
um can you clarify what actually
happened there because I kind of felt as
if I would have heard if it had been
decided but um that would that would be
helpful
we heard
of course have declined to give
permission for an appeal
but we um
decision yes over the way the Supreme
Court works is you don't you're not
allowed to go there automatically you
have to ask
on paper usually for three judges look
at it and decide if you you ought to be
allowed to have a full Hearing in the
Supreme Court and I can probably find it
if you I've got it somewhere
if we reference it properly somewhere in
our
decision notice when we get there I
think that would be
quite helpful
he forms past the background to your
consideration but it's it was the
Supreme Court declined to give
permission as they very often do they
are numerous they only hear a very small
minority of cases that were dealt with
yeah yeah that's that's that's fine yeah
so for the avoidance of doubt I think is
Mr Isabel's usual phrase
sorry
um councilman councilman had two two
parts to his question I think my my
colleague the chief wishes to address
when did The Five-Year housing land
Supply change
so chairman the land Supply we don't
monitor on a day-to-day basis and this
is understood and agreed to be done
through the annual monitoring report
we were last at Committee in September
2020 with this
the monitoring report for 2019 2020 was
published in October 2020. I don't have
the specific date when it was published
at that time the land Supply was
7.67 years
and the following year 2020 2021 uh was
published in December 2021 and I'm just
looking at the document now to give you
the position as it was
then
um and not doing very well but if I can
come back to you I'll do that but
literally for 2020 uh the land Supply
position was set out in the annual
monitoring report which post-dated the
hearing of the committee and it wasn't
as sizable as it is now thank you
see
a 7.67 I think was was what was in in
October 2020 was the position that we
reported to as cleverable sites but that
would have been after the meeting
so at the time I haven't been able to
get the figure for
the application so what I'd hoped to do
my report was report the previous figure
which was less than five I believe it
was yeah well I believe it was less than
7.68 whether or not it was below five or
it was close I haven't been now to
ascertain
yeah I think that's chairman with your
agreement if I can dig that outcome back
in due course I'm just going through the
papers
sure um I've got um
a couple of questions about the
um pedestrian cycle access but uh the
other question I've got is I'm a little
bit intrigued by what you said about the
um the surgery uh because surely people
from from Thurston are more likely to go
to Morton hall or ex-worth than debenham
I'm intrigued by the debenham bit uh on
the um uh pedestrian cycle access
um can you to inform me if there is any
um
uh connection from the in with inside
the development that well actually well
inside the development onto the footpath
that runs along the southern edge of the
development side there is a public
footpath that backs onto the existing
housing there and the bit of pavement or
psychopath or whatever it is that the
developer is proposing on the south side
of the access point
and you've got a pedestrian Crossing to
the side where the school is and all the
rest of it does that bit of bike path
actually link with the exit from the
footpath onto that road that's my first
point about the
um footpath pedestrian thing
um and the uh tiger Crossings
um on the um Norton roads mixworth Road
um uh and they're that crossroads uh is
there any access from the Norton Road
Direction where the new primary school
is if you're coming out of the old
primary the new Primary School can you
access that new type of Crossing because
it looked like it went straight into the
housing estate not the Norton Road bit
and on your diagram of the proposed
skate park
um maybe I missed the cursor because I
wasn't aware I had to look with eyes at
the back of my head
um there was a distance marker of 81
meters to the corner and I couldn't
quite work out what relevance that had
because it didn't look like it were
anywhere near the skate pods or whatever
they were called sorry if that's all a
bit garbled thank you
foreign
obviously we've got the primary school
to the east as part of the Lawrence home
scheme there would be
connections across their Frontage which
would then link to the the cycle
connections that in provided by linden
homes
for which there's a Crossing
over Norton Road there's potentially
another Crossing this side of that
those sites here but as stands you would
still have to cross
from this side
to this side
so this scheme does not include
extending footways on the North side or
providing any Crossing Point
what sort of what I meant was if you
were coming I I realized it's nothing to
do with Norton Road but it's to do with
the tiger Crossing if you were coming
out of Norton Road how would you get to
the tiger Crossing is that pavement or
do you have to actually just you know if
you're Crossing to get to the school
from the to the high school from the
primary school direction are you
expected to go around the road onto the
tiger Crossing or is there actually a
link these these dotted lines are
existing links
so what we are doing is connecting with
the tiger Crossing existing Links at
that point
just as an aside further improvements
would be delivered by the Lawrence it's
off of that screen Lawrence Holmes as
the Linden homes have already provided
but at some point you would still need
and I believe it's part of the first and
five would be a crossing somewhere along
here so that you could get from the
north side to the south side
this scheme would not provide that
Crossing in term s of
skate park
sorry this is a bit live and you have to
tap your head and
concentrate
yeah
you're quite right insofar as this has
no relevance to
the distance from the
skate dots to residential that's just
showing you the maximum depth
at that corner however
this is where the currently the
attenuation Basin is proposed but were
for some reason you to take the skate
dots around the back of that then that
may be may be relevant but really it's
just highlighting
the depth of this and it is a
significant piece of open
space
so there was there was also a question
about the foot path on the southern side
of the development is there a link to
the new bit of pavement and are there
any links within the development
slide with the
so this
this section in here is where the
footpath runs at the at the moment and
I'll go to a different slide that shows
that so this is actually taken from the
estate Road
so that part is within the road
but as you say the footpath comes out at
this point and would be connected via
this Crossing
there isn't a second section in here all
so we could actually get the three meter
section to go up to the site boundary
which would actually then connect to
that
path I I see the point you're making
Council
that ought to be green as well in order
so that it can pick up
were members minded to
suggest that they would have continued
to Grant planning permission that would
have been something we could have either
added to the 106 or secured by condition
and is your debenham surgery the right
one yeah I saw heads moving I I defer to
local
knowledge at the time when I researched
it the answer was you have to go to warp
it or
yeah if I could help chair yeah page 99
of our papers I I was on the committee
and when we did this before and I
remember there was something there and
it says it's on page 99 and the
discussion there about capacity Etc
looks at Mount Farm which extremely
that's the berry one isn't it and it's
worth
um surgeries
strategy it doesn't actually mention
ball pit but um
certainly um Debenhams a long way off of
the um off the Beaten Track and but
there is the referencing there on page
99 so that's uh we did deal with that
before
there was it actually one other thing
that I'd made a note of on my Scrappy
piece of paper
um you talked about extensive
Landscaping on all four sides of the
development and yet the very very
beginning of your presentation you
talked about the visibility display
cutting across a bit of open space now
on the plans it looks like there are
some bushes there so
um can you just confirm if they're
actually going to be any planting meal
where that has to be kept completely
bare for visibility on the on the side
of the road
of scrubby
Hedgerow
the point of access that would be lost
within this section there is very little
cluster may also have to to go to
accommodate the visibility splay but in
place of the loss of that P
epe tree there and this little cluster
this entire belt in here between the
green and the yellow lines
would actually be a dense planting new
planting
so in the same way as we get a 20 meter
additional buffer down this
down this that edge and we get all of
this open space we also get that dense
buffer along here our view at the time
was that actually reinforces the
character of Vicks with Road better than
the position at the moment where most of
the former Hedgerow over the over time
has been grubbed up
thank you
no
um thank you chair um thanks for the
presentation Vince
um just in the recommendation on page 41
um you don't mention the neighborhood
plan
at all as a um as part of that
recommendation for refusal
is that because because obviously their
policy one is about settlement boundary
is that because of the word focused
or it's my first question and secondly
whether it is or it isn't do that should
should the the fact that there is a
neighborhood plan and what the neighbor
plans trying to do be included as an
important refusal thank you
the recommendation has not cited the
neighborhood plan
on the basis
you're quite right that the policy one
suggests that development should be
focused Within settlement boundary and
the outcome from the
court cases was that the judges
determined that focused
does not mean development outside of the
settlement boundary should be refused
focused allows development outside of
the
settlement boundary what the court of
appeal did say was that
refusal based on an application being
contrary to the council's adopted
development plan I.E development in the
countryside is
a reasonable and appropriate approach so
his offices what we are suggesting is
that we
we direct our attention to our adopted
development plan because this is quite
clearly not allocated in that and it is
clearly
Countryside
and therefore
logically
a judges said about
case holds true for this this site
okay now that makes sense and can I just
come back that
um just to check that there aren't
I'm assuming therefore there aren't any
other policies within the neighborhood
plan that would
um
support that refusal as it were that
would be
um
that you one might want to if one was
recommending
um refuse or might want to strengthen
that recommendation but
so I'm just you know not just Chuck
kitchen sink in as it were but just if
there is anything
just to reassure us that that's what
we've got is the kind of optimum if you
say to me
chairman I mean we've
come to you with a recommendation which
we believe is defensible and credible on
a review of the considerations
we've taken legal advice on the papers
before you as to the accuracy of that
relative to the outcome of the court
case and
the considerations that have changed I
think our original application of the
neighborhood plan policies remains as we
set out in the original report the
materiality of change
is a land Supply question and that's
described by the examination inspectors
so our view about the application of the
interpretation
of the neighborhood plan is as you have
in the papers and we're not looking to
add anything else I think from our point
of view this is a cogent analysis of the
planning circumstance
well admin clearly have a position they
have followed that through to complete a
section 106 and Obama shouting that
would have been an issued decision
um and I think from our point of view we
have a case which label doubt let's
argue but this is defensible and
credible
thanks that's very helpful thank you
very much
well if I identified improvements to
Road Junctions the tiger crosses the
toucan Crossing
and a contribution to
um at bambury's
at the Banbury arms and also funding
towards improving safety at the railway
station
um I think of course I mean obviously if
this
development is refused then we'll lose
that contribution
do other developer are other
developments that have
under construction in Thurston making a
contribution to these
in safety improvements and would it
still be possible for these improvements
to carry on
a very good question counselor I'm sure
we'll hear from the parish council at
the moment we are in dialogue with the
parish council and our County colleagues
as to how the first and five Highway
monies because there was a considerable
contribution towards Highway
improvements has been spent
in Thurston in terms of improvements
um
the
I'm just thinking in and of themselves
the 106 that relates to the third and
five I believe does not particularly
particularly identify improvements
improvements to the station
I think what Thurston Parish Council are
trying to get to the bottom of these how
much money of the of the original Psalm
is left and what could that be used for
in terms of what you see on the screen
today in terms of improvements to their
Junction
potentially could be funded from other
sources if you didn't give planning
permission for this scheme
how much of it could be funded from
let's say the first and five pot it's
not clear how much of that is left
anecdotally
I'm told by County colleagues that there
is very little left and it certainly
wouldn't fund the tiger Crossing for
example now
I think
our friends from the parish council are
skeptical as to whether that is is true
I can only say what I've been told and
it is only hearsay I'm sure that the
parish council and ourselves are waiting
for some sort of evidence from the
county that's audited to show how that
money has been spent
so I think
the long answer to your question
counselor was yes other schemes could
fund those it's unclear whether there is
money in the pot at the moment to fund
them
whether or not still could be used or
the county funds could be used
we don't know all I can see is that
gladman have insured through the 106.
games that they've committed to can be
funded
and now in that sense guaranteed if
development
implemented those
could be provided because the money is
included in that 106.
sorry can I just uh yeah sorry Council
you're the chief can you tell me
I just wanted to
at one point the highway authorities
comments are predicated on I no
objection to the scheme are predicated
on the Baton Road improvements so if you
corner and others all being in place
before development on this site
starts
because we have the 106 Baton Road
were you minded to ground planning
permission for this scheme we'd have to
have
ensured that development didn't start
ahead of the Fishwick Corner works
because this scheme benefits in terms of
Highway capacity from those work surf
the Railway Bridge
unless we're in the position of
recommending refusal
we don't have to deal with that no
that's a traffic lights yes
thank you
chairman if I can just come back I think
which councilman Matheson raised a
question about when the land Supply
changed
so the position statement the housing
land Supply position statement issued in
September 2019 said the council had a
land supply of 5.66 years
housing land Supply statement issued in
October 2020
and I don't know when said the land
Supply was 7.67 years
and the housing land Supply statement
for uh the following year 2021 which was
issued in February 22
stated that the land supply for that was
9.54 years so you can see a clear
trajectory there
of increasing Supply
but obviously at the time that we
reported to you in September 2020 the
information we had
because our Consultants had not reported
back to us in final form was that the
land Supply was 5.66 years
I mean clearly it would be foolish to
think that permissions had not been
granted since September 2019 but we did
not have precise calculation as the
effect that it had on the land Supply
one other one other other little point
just I'm very conscious we need to be
absolutely absolutely absolutely clear
and correct in every word we say when
when officers were talking about the the
um draft jlp which I think probably is
the submission draft of the jlp
um who spoke about jlp allocation I
think we would have to say that was a
proposed allocation at that time so um
just for absolute clarity thank you
I could I would concur thank you
counselor
sorry this is a question that follows on
from the response we got from councilor
War boys
um queries about the road improvements
um you said that the should this get
permission it was predicated on the
um improvements tied in with the Baton
row development to be in place
um what about the Improvement at the
Bunbury arms Crossing
um because you mentioned something about
this would be an Envy should this get
permission though since to be some
enhanced some some sort of special thing
going on at the Bunbury arms Junction
um
but there's no is there a time
constraint on that because of course
that most of the As I understood for
Thurston five were meant to be providing
money to do something with the Bunbury
arms Junction and as to my knowledge
last time I was there it looked the same
as normal so I'm assuming that all those
houses have been built and a lot of them
are occupied in Thurston now is there a
Time by which that Bunbury arms needs to
have something done by
and is that going to be linked into this
at all in any way
if members were minded to indicate that
they
would approve this application that is
something we would have to look into and
report back on
in the same
way that we're waiting for information
as to
what the first and five monies has
funded we also are looking to see
how much of the Bunbury arms
improvements has already been allocated
from that
pot but you're quite right if we're
minded to Grant permission then we would
need to ensure that not just
the works I've described but also the
Bunbury arms is also linked to a
commencement on the
on this just as
the Clapping site benefits from the
Baton Road improvements it also benefits
from the Bunbury arms
improvements
thank you chair thank you for the report
the
I just want to explore the traffic cams
because I remember the previous meeting
where we were relying on software to be
able to get the traffic flows to a safe
position but that was obviously Based on
data several years ago
when was the latest traffic
how old is the traffic data we are
basing this current decision on
the report
reflects the position two and a half
years ago we have not first part we have
not had an updated
um traffic assessment
I am that
that would have take for taken into
account a five-year
growth period of traffic
it would have reflected permissions that
had been granted and I believe it on
this one here it also would have
factored in
the Baton decision that's why they
offered the money for the
so there hasn't been an updated traffic
assessment since you last considered
this in September but the information we
received at the time would have been
forecasting five years ahead
Okay so
so if we were to do the assessment again
we'd know if the forecast was correct
wouldn't we
it may or may not come up with a
different answer yes
um yes oh this is a bizarre pathetical
as well why we're on the sort of
subject of perhaps sort of looking for
further information
um
I'm assuming here that the Wastewater
treatment at first of water recycling
center is part of Anglia water
or is it independent to Bangla water
I do not know the answer to that I would
have to check
um because there's many things we've
moved on with traffic and or whatever
we've also
moved on with what we the sort of
information we were requiring from
Anglia water
um to go beyond about a sort of blanket
statement saying they have available
capacity that we were looking for
additional information if you like is
what that meant
so
would that be having said I do not know
the answer I'm going to correct myself
in so far as
in terms of
Wheaton Road reserved matters
due to
become Committee in
15th of March
updated response from anglian water I
believe
I believe it's saying that they had no
objection to that
scheme
presupposes
there is capacity to accommodate
that whether or not something has
happened in the intervening two and a
half years as the other sites have been
built out whether they've taken steps to
enhance their capacity
but in terms of the bait and Road scheme
special
February they have no
now move on to the public speakers and
I'd like to call the parish council
representative Julian West but I believe
Mrs Waples you're there for questions I
believe okay Mr West you have three
minutes
thank you
over the past four years and for at
least the next five years the person
will be undergoing an unprecedented
level of development
two of the first and the five
developments are nearing completion and
following the successful appeal relating
to the blur application a further 210
properties are to be built within the
village over the next few years plus the
much needed Care Home provision of 54
residences
additionally since 2017 The Village
expansion has included nine properties
on barrels Road nine Flats at The
Granary and a possible further 97 Flats
to be built in total Thurston currently
has planning permissions in place for
over 1250 new homes
despite this level of development
mitigation for these new homes currently
extends to just the new Primary School
which is a result of the blood
development will already be requiring an
extension and some minimal highways and
Junction improvements no additional
commercial retail health or community
space or facilities have been provided
to person outside of the mandatory Green
Space and play area provision for each
site
no solution has been provided to solve
the safety issue on the railway station
Crossing despite the developers being
instructed to work on the issue as part
of their Plumbing approvals
due to its glacial progress to date the
parish council has lost any confidence
in network rail addressing this
situation in the foreseeable future
the application proposes nothing in
addition in terms of mitigation for the
increased volume of traffic and pressure
on the road Network created by proposed
new homes
the required improvements to the Bunbury
arms Junction on the a143 still appear
to be completely Pie in the Sky with no
evidence being produced of any progress
to date
contrary to the report by the officer
first he's not well served by buses
ixsworth road which Services the
proposed development is a narrow Country
Road in very poor condition with a
number of bends and restricted views on
oncoming traffic
Suffolk highways have made reference to
the safety issues with poor sight lines
and visibility splays on the road in
other planning applications notably the
seat is close and for the Thurston
Community College
any additional exits onto this
carriageway will only add to the
existing safety issues whilst The
increased traffic will impact further on
the other principal Junctions within the
village
all of the developments have a negative
impact on traffic flows and therefore
air quality and the achievement of
measures to support the council's
Declaration of a climate emergency
the latest officer report notes that the
council currently has a 10.88 year land
Supply there is no longer a draft
allocation of development sites within
the emerging jlp and therefore there is
no demountable need for this development
to go ahead
Thurston Parish urges the committee to
reject this application today should
this application be approved first and
we'll end up with yet another massive
development that nobody wants is no
longer required to meet the development
targets and will not have an necessary
infrastructure improvements to support
to the
do we have questions please for the
parish members
no questions at all
okay thank you very much indeed
uh
award members councilor Davis and
councilor Richardson so Council Davis if
you would like to go first please
thank you
thank you chair
um
yes rather than going through a speech
what I'd like to do with firstly say
that I fully support
Mr wet's comments about our community's
reaction to this application
I thank our officers for all the work
they've done in
looking again at the housing Supply and
coming to the conclusion that
they recommend a refusal which are
enthusiastically support
I was puzzled if not possibly appalled
by a comment that the County Council
highways has already spent the over 900
000 pounds which the five
um
in existing developers have contributed
to the s-106s
we do have some Crossing points outside
the new primary school but outside of
that there's been zip in the way of
Highway improvements
and certainly initial discussions with
highways indicated that there would be
some flexibility in reorientating the
funds that have been paid to Suffolk
County Council to improve the crossing
points outside the
[Music]
in terms of the network rail 30gb 30
grand for a feasibility studies
were all acutely aware
we've contributed
a hundred thousand of our sale money for
the feasibility studies so
we just await the arrival of network
rail
uh I think that'll about do me for now
thank you thank you very much indeed
councilor Davis Casey Richardson please
lovely thank you very much chair I will
be brief as I agree with much of what's
been said already similar to councilor
Davies as one of the uh or the other
Ward member I'd like to endorse the
officer's recommendation for refusal and
would thank them for reviewing and
revisiting this application in light of
the changes outlined in the report
members will be aware as award even
reference has been a significant amount
of development in Thurston since the
first major planning application was
approved at appeal in October 2017. so
we are some some way down this journey
and I think we've already seen the
accumulative impact of the development
s in Thurston obviously you've heard
that two are nearing completion already
um
obviously this site as you've heard is
outside of the settlement boundary it is
in the open Countryside and is not
allocated for growth or isn't proposed
as an allocation for growth I should say
um and all of those obviously are
material considerations and one thing I
will just highlight
um off the back of the presentation is
that for the skateboarding proposals
those have been superseded Now by a
current scheme at a different site which
although it's it's far from being
completed is relatively Advanced so that
benefits associated with this
application is no longer relevant I
would argue
um and so for those reasons
um as you've heard from the office's
presentation the relative benefit versus
the relative harm and now that the
situation has changed after three years
um I would ask members to refuse the
application or to provide reputative
reason for refusal in the papers if
indeed this application is appealed
which I believe it will be
um I must just say on a final note that
it is rather disappointing
um that the uh applicants themselves are
absent I think it's probably worth
putting on record the fact that
engagement both with and from gladman
has been minimal
um to say the least
um so I I think that's that's especially
disappointing
um but I'll leave it there because I I
don't want to repeat what's already been
said
um so thank you very much chair happy to
take any questions if there are any but
I must apologize in advance I'm not able
to stay for the debate but I'm happy to
answer any questions if members do
thank you very much Katie Richardson do
we have any questions please to the ward
members
councilor War boys please
I'm not sure whether Ward members uh
gonna answer this no I might go back to
the Post Council if that's
um have suffocate oh it's apparently
quite clear I think the expression is
zip in the way of Highway improvements
uh have the suffocate highways being
approached with regard to some sort of
statement as to how the substantial
funds they've already received been
spent and how much has been left I'm
remains sorry
thank you uh thank you Council boys I
think the uh the answer is yes an
approach has been made but a full and
detailed answer has not been forthcoming
as yet
thank you
do we have any further questions for the
ward members
no
Matheson
yes that's fine we'll have we'll break
for five minutes please
I'll Now open up the uh
application for debate who would like to
kick off please
counselor
mayor yeah so it's getting late four
years not sorry
obviously made a big impression
yeah thank you um
whilst no decision is is straightforward
this one isn't straightforward but I
think
I find
that actually the material changes are
highly significant
the allocation
opposed allocation is not now in the jlp
and our land Supply would allow us to
deliver everything that we need to
deliver by 2036. so we do not need these
houses
so are the benefits so
high that that outweighs that decision
and to my mind no I think the officers
report um
was balanced hit the nail on the head
and I'm very happy to support that
recommendation
recommendation and propose that we
refuse planning permission
yeah happy to second that chair uh but
I'll say that and qualify that I I would
have actually liked to have seen an
up-to-date highways assessment here
because if the actuality
of the traffic movements at Bunbury arms
is greater than the forecast
it would mean that the software
mitigation proposed wouldn't mitigate
but we don't know that because we
haven't got an up-to-date traffic
assessment
I would have personally liked to have
seen that but I'm still happy to Second
the refusal uh however
just to say but going through the years
of of needing in excess of five-year
land Supply that that seven years nine
years and ten years plus are all above
five
so and I understand why 10 years plus is
significantly more than five
but but even when we originally were
visiting this we had in excess of five
years as a land Supply having said that
that doesn't uh that doesn't preclude me
from seconding what is quite a
comprehensive report uh despite my small
misgivings uh and and happy to secure
this and I'll be voting with the officer
recommendation thank you
thank you chairman
um listening to what councilor Stringer
was saying and accepting that we're in a
situation where this is likely go to
appeal clearly this will be put before
another decision maker
one could if one chose and this is up to
the proposal and segment of the motion
and an informative decision to invite
the inspector to give serious
consideration to a review of that issue
we're not necessarily raising it as a
matter of refusal here
but to express that this is something
which public confidence in the appeal
process will be gained by going over
that matter so
um I I would say that if the proposal in
second are wished to an informative to
invite the inspector to review that
matter in order that there is public
confidence in their decision would be
something we could add to the decision
yeah happy
yes thank you uh well I I've I voted
against this originally so I'm I'm not
going to change my opinion clearly and
um yeah I think the one of the reasons I
didn't
fought it then was was doubts about the
the ability of a sort of Fairly untried
Etc software to um mitigate what was
undoubtedly going to be an awful lot of
extra traffic I think
um officers might correctly I think we
must have taken this decision then
um soon after the the first and five
which I was not party to in fact as a
member of the committee
um and so
that that really particularly the
traffic weighed in addition to the to
the the doubts about need and and um
I don't really quite understand how the
appeal court came to the decision that
it did about what Focus meant this is 20
of the um
the numbers
in in the neighborhood plan and I would
have thought Focus would have
to a smaller number than 20 percent
being outside the neighborhood plan so
that's um
that's just another
sense of that isn't going to affect our
decision today actually so uh actually
support the recommendation and um yeah
thank you chair
um I agree with my um colleague
councilor mayor in terms of the you know
this it's a complex
um
issues with this development
particularly in the context of of
Thurston and what's been already
approved there
um but I'm pleased to see that this is a
refusal and I feel satisfied that the
arguments from the officers
and having had got legal advice and so
on on that recommendation and I think
that in this instance I think we should
be
supporting the community of Thurston
um particularly in
um helping them to gain benefits and
infrastructure benefits from from the
developments that are taking place there
and and also supporting them in the fact
that there is no need for this
development given the amount of Housing
Development we've got and the
land Supply that we've got of 10.88
years so I will be supporting the
officer recommendation thank you Joe
thank you chair I I too will be fully
supporting the current proposal that
we've got on the table
and similarly to councilor Mathison I
too voted against this development last
time I also get voted against the vast
majority of the thirst and five on the
basis that I wouldn't be parted to any
any decision that put Jeopardy onto the
railway station and I am I think it is I
think we're in a sad and sorry state
that we are over five years on from that
first and five decision with the Bunbury
arm the promise of the Improvement of
the Bunbury arms Junction uh the promise
of something that would be done about
the railway station and as yet a vast
number of those houses in Thurston are
now occupied and we're nowhere nowhere
near we haven't moved any further
forward on either of those issues so
adding another 210 houses into the mix
uh and of course that's on top of the
Dayton road development is only going to
make things worse so I I fully support
the refusal and I and I thank the
officers for doing the work to get the
grounds for refusal
um
strong enough to hold up at the any
appear any future appeal so I will be
voting for the current recommendation
for refusal
thank you chair uh I like I think I'd
like to thank the
planning office have taken us through
the material changes and make it quite
clear
how that has made it possible for us to
refuse this application
I think from Mr
Isabel's remarks I think it opens the
the scope for
you know just bringing to the surface
that um Suffolk highways and a network
rail have been part of the discussions
about these developments and they have
um accepted that there's the need for
improvements in safety in these sites
and they've and consequently they've
accepted the ever duty of care towards
The increased traffic at these sites as
a result of the extra developments
and as I said I think from what was this
bill's comments were that this will be
taken to the planning inspector and they
will be able to comment on on that
um they have received substantial
amounts the funds may have disappeared
and as we all know costs have increased
over the last five years so it's making
it's extremely unlikely that we're going
to be able to catch up with the
increased costs without further
development and that's an invidious
position for us to find ourselves as a
development as a referral committee so I
will be supported the palings offices
recommendations
um
that I do think suffocailers have sort
of neglected
to carry this forward
sorry a question and um this is not
meant as a criticism in any way but
given that this may go to a
an appeal I'm slightly concerned my
comment made by councilor Matheson in
that he says I voted against this before
and clearly I'm not going to change my
mind
um would it would it be better and I
probably can't tell you is is that a
sense can we say that is that going to
damage our decision I
that's a
wrong thing to say I mean actually that
there is case law from the high court
court for appeals saying consistency and
public decision making is is an
important principle and that sometimes
if you are
going to change your mind from an
earlier decision you need to explain why
but that's talking about the council
collectively rather than an individual
member who is entitled to think again
and say well I thought that three years
ago but I now think something different
having had further reflection but it's
it doesn't unduly worry me as your legal
advisor
yeah
um what I I should have said was that
the the reasons that I refused it then
have been strengthened by subsequent
change material considerations changing
they've only changed to make it more
certain that I would vote against
thank you very much I won't repeat the
reasons why we're talking about refusing
this but I think they're good strong
reasons for appeal but um
I just wanted to say that it's
it's with pleasure that I make this
decision because I've been on planning
committees before we had this land
Supply and that weight of that need
when deciding an application I have not
enjoyed that one bit having a real high
weight on the need and to come out of
that
although there has been a lot of
development done and there's been a big
sacrifice in Thurston
for the land Supply
to come out of that is a really is a
really good thing for me but um yeah
fully support this this is a um this is
a good decision I think it's strong for
appeal
um yeah thank you
chair um yes I agree with what
colleagues have said
um
I don't actually recall whether I was
involved in the previous decision I
certainly can't remember how I voted but
um certainly we've had a very very clear
presentation a very detailed one and I'm
confident in the uh the reasons which
are given for refusal it does seem to me
um faintly ridiculous that we cannot
seem to get network rail to pull their
finger out and do this work
to um to look at the station and see
what can be done we've we've put aside a
hundred thousand pounds they
side again for them
um so if anything uh you know if if
anyone in the public domain is watching
this if there's any way we can get
pressure on uh Network rail it'd be
wonderful to see some movement on that
and we had a very near accident uh at
that station last year uh I would hate
to see someone injured because progress
had not been made there
um so um
I'm happily going to vote for
the officer's recommendation on this
occasion thank you
and just as a point of information
chairman I was in a conversation this
morning with um Christine Thurlow and
colleagues regarding uh the situation
with Rail and there's there's there's
still a will and a conversation going on
about providing infrastructure I think
we all regret the slowness of which that
conversation is taking place but it is
not forgotten it is not gone but Network
Ray Lara curious organization to deal
with
right no okay then I will sort of make
my comments um I'd like to thank Vincent
for his uh very detailed report thank
you for that I fully agree with the
comments made by my fellow members here
and also the parish council and I too
will be supporting the recommendation to
a refusal for this application thank you
um Mr Isabel did you wish to make any
comment before we go to the vote at all
chairman the only comment I'd make is
that the proposal before you is one for
a ring use an or putative reason for
refusal if by the time officers get to
issue the decision the appeal has been
formalized and lodged which is not
impossible and therefore as long as the
Authority for whatever is decided here
today allows for both actions then we
can take that forward and uh Claire has
the the text around informative and just
for clarity I'll read that to you I'd
suggest if the president is secondary
are happy with that that the council
notes the interest and concern locally
regarding the mitigation of Highway
issues and the interest uh of and in the
interests of public confidence invites
the Secretary of State's inspect to
ensure to ensure that this aspect is
given proper review in reaching their
decision at the forthcoming appeal now I
mean the appeal might not get hurt but I
think the balance of probability is that
there will be an appeal and this will
take place
your informative's talking about
uh I've said highways issues so I've
left it open but I think clearly from
Adam's Pages we have advice technically
which is in the papers
I think what gives public confidences
for the inspector appointed to ensure
that is given sufficient review that the
community feels that's been looked at
clearly the parish may have a position
on that that they will wish to argue
thank you very much I now ask the
governor's officer to conduct the
electronic vote please thank you
thank you
and then progress Council Australia can
I take your vote please
thank you
yes thank you
thank you so chair that is nine votes
for refusal thank you thank you very
much indeed thank you unanimous thank
you very much indeed uh I'd like to
thank everybody for attending today and
I will now formally closed the meeting
at 16 20. thank you very much